je m'aperçois que les filles de la
campagne ne tiennent pas tellement à se
marier avec un gars de campagne parce
qu'elles veulent aller plutôt vers la
ville une femme aime bien son dimanche
son samedi alors que dans l'agriculture
on n'est pas libre me trouve assez bien
comme ça vous savez j'ai 22 ans et demi
je me trouve très bien comme ça et vous
pensez trouver l'âme sœur à la fois au
célibataire
va pas comment on veut on ne prend pas
n'importe qui vaut mieux coucher tout
seul quelque chose qu'on aime pas
j'étais pour me marier et puis j'étais
trompée avant le mariage alors j'ai
abandonné celui qui s'est passé il est
souvent à mieux seul qu'elle était avec
une femme qui n'y connaît rien qu'elle a
pas mal qui Nicole c'est pas grave
avec l'espoir de trouver quelqu'un ah
oui mais pas pour peut-être pas pour le
mariage sûrement pas ça vous a pas
manqué quand même un homme tout au long
de votre vie
un ou deux